we are always
wrestling with how to phrase this or
where to stand so that you can actually
see what's going on and increasingly i
think we've got some of the right
elements
um on the table you know we've talked
about an autoimmune
reaction this a lot of this protest is
attacking the very things that make
um things functional we've talked about
the verificationism
that allows people to arrive at these
crazy
conclusions we've talked about the fact
that the
the uh movement itself appears to be
involved in a kind of collective
psychosis
but you've also talked about this
the snitches analogy yeah that there's
something about what is being said
that appears to be devoid of content
it's just group identifier stuff and it
could be as arbitrary as a star on your
belly
right and that we are confused by the
fact that there is content like oh we
should definitely defund the police
like that sounds like an argument we
should definitely defund the police
sounds like an analytical conclusion
that arises from an analysis rather than
you know like you know it could just as
easily be oh
you know i hum at this pit right
you know yes you do well i do now but um
but anyway
so i've been wrestling with how to put
these things together how to even think
about them correctly
yeah and i came up with this model which
unfortunately i'm going to hold up on a
piece of paper which is kind of old
school but
um anyway let's see here's my piece of
paper here's the model
that we are we live here in this gully
and the point is the political winds can
push this ball one direction or the
other and it tends to
revert back to the middle you know the
liberals can get a little overly
enthusiastic with some of their
solution making and you know things
don't quite work out and then the
conservatives
say told you so was never going to work
and they dragged things back a little
bit
too far and we lose some of the gains
that can go on
indefinitely because what this is this
this depression there is mathematically
speaking a
stable equilibrium now the points i have
labeled a and b
here those are unstable equilibria
and the point is if you push this ball
far enough it reaches one of these
unstable equilibria and the next thing
that happens is you end up down here
wherever that is and my claim is going
to be
this doesn't have to be fascism and
communism
but it might as well be the point is a
historical process that pushes that ball
up to either a or b
results in a catastrophic uh
destabilization a disintegration of
something that
was keeping you safe and so my point is
you don't always like it where you're in
this gully here
but it's tolerable and what happens once
you go over one of these unstable
equilibrium points
is you end up somewhere completely
intolerable and the real
question for us is a what does that
and i'm going to argue that the snitch's
business has a lot to do with it that
the thing that tends to push you
over the edge is something that
historically causes you
instead of thinking about things
analytically to default to team
okay but okay so snatches you know mask
wearing sneakers and sneetches without
maga hat wearing sneetches and sneetches
with that it's all the same thing right
but the tribes that are defined by the
maga hat and the masks and
the stars on the bellies and all of the
rest
are then slotted by their enemies into
particular buckets and so you know we
have pointed out often
uh that at least used to be i'm not sure
if it still is but on the official black
lives matter
page we see um and you know in
interviews
with the founders we see them saying
actually
this is marxist we're trained in marxist
stuff and that's what we're trying to do
and so you know to your point oh is it
you know is it communism is it fascism
is it marxism is it fascism it doesn't
need to be but those do seem to be the
two poles that we are
um oscillating between at least in terms
of mainstream media right now
and part of the problem i think
this is maybe not exactly to your point
but i do think that part of the problem
is
there are many of us actually on the
left including many people on the right
who were saying oh my god that's that's
that's marxism that they're
proclaiming because they're actually
saying it and you should believe them
when they say that that's actually what
they're doing because it looks like it
and also
they don't deny it so what the hell and
by the way look at these 18 examples
from history where marxism doesn't work
so let's not go there
on the other side you've got people
saying
trump's ascendancy to office is clearly
uh
an indicator that we're about to descend
into fascism and
there are um you know some people on the
right who
who see that there are pretty much
everyone in the far left you know the
people who are actually rioting and some
number of the people who are protesting
on the streets see it that way
but there are also many of us on the
left who say
don't like the guy disagree with these
policies don't think he's fit for office
but it doesn't look fascist right so um
we on the left can simultaneously say
don't want that particular executive
branch
to maintain but in terms of are we
struggling between communism and fascism
it actually doesn't look like this thing
over in the republican party right now
is
is fascist well no it so
i agree with that to an extent okay my
real point is that there is tribalism
that exists in this well
right in the well there's normal
tribalism you've got elephants
and donkeys under the best of
circumstances and it's not inherently
bad
right what you have is a tension between
arguments
right those who want less meddling and
more freedom and therefore
are willing to tolerate more failure
more people falling off the bottom of
the ladder or something
our intention with those who um
want to make sure that bad things don't
befall you and so they will actually
remove too much of the incentive for you
to do good things
right so those two things are actual
arguments
right and where we are is something that
reasonable people can disagree over and
where we should want to be is some place
reasonable people can disagree over
my point is that those unstable
equilibria the two high
points from which you descend into
madness are places where
there is no argument what we effectively
start doing
is teaming up for violence and
this is the thing that i'm concerned
about is that history has some
mechanism as far as i know it doesn't
have a name right we might have a
description of it when things descend
into
marxism we might have a description of
it when things descend into fascism
as far as i know we don't have a
description for the general pattern
of a functional society that is ebbing
and flowing
has hit a tipping point and that tipping
point goes to this other
type of behavior and that other type of
behavior ends in
warfare genocide all of these things and
so that's what i'm hunting for is i
think we are
we are now watching and all of the
people that we are in contact with are
now
grappling with how to describe what they
are seeing we are debating over stuff
that literally i mean you know we've
been at are we really arguing about
whether males and females
are different at a biological level like
how could a conversation ever get that
dumb
it's inconceivable we're now doing this
with two plus two equals five
right is it possible the conversation
will ever get that dumb yeah it actually
apparently is that dumb
i will say that my own failure of
imagination cannot
figure out what gets dumber than that
one it's hard to get done i'm waiting
but my but my point is
you have hit bottom we have hit bottom
on something
and that is the degree to which what we
are arguing over has
anything to do with an analysis of any
kind
at the point you are arguing about two
plus two equals five you are declaring
that you no longer care
about what is actual right um
it's pure solipsism and so my point is
pure solipsism is the adult version
of stars on your bellies so
to those who would say but the other
side is fascism
anything is better than that it doesn't
matter as much
maybe that we say you know what i don't
even think that's fascism
it what matters more is actual
intellectual solipsism
is the end full stop like that that is
where you lose
all access to the gains from the last
300 years right so
this is this is the point about
autoimmunity is that the
people who are arguing against logic
itself
right and those who have signed up with
them and are making excuses for them
are arguing against what we have
in favor of something they claim we
could have
now my point would be every single test
of
their intuition about what we could have
descends into madness almost instantly
so we are listening to insane people who
have a claim about a world better than
this one
and we are no longer listening to people
who say this world has a hell of a lot
going for it
and the only right thing to do is to fix
the parts that didn't get there
to complete the project rather than
destroy the project we are in that
argument
and we are losing ground to the people
who want to destroy this world in the
hope or in the expectation that
something marvelous
as they see it will arise in its place
the only
uh we are losing ground because their
argument is no longer
an argument it is a threat
expand on that a little bit we are
losing ground ah we are losing ground
because
it's it it all sounded to er to all of
us like we were in conversation
and then it turns out no actually what
was maybe thinly veiled
is now just full-on threat yes and that
the way that this looks
i mean i'm beginning to get frustrated
with um
with our circle because our circle is
seeing so much
of this nonsense that it is just it
thinks its job is to catalog it have you
seen this crazy example have you seen
that crazy example look at what this
person claimed oh my god it's gotten
even worse
right and my point is that that will
work for some people people who haven't
yet seen it being
being presented with a list a catalog
i feel a little like invoking yoda and
i'm not a huge star wars fan but i am
kind of a huge yoda fan
um there is no try there's do
and don't do right my point is
our circle being fascinated by all of
the various examples
is missing the boat because we're about
to lose the thing that is
feeding us that will provide our
descendants with the place
to exist and experience freedom and all
of these things
and the reason we are losing it
is because you know those who are good
at analysis
default to it when something comes in a
form
we are purely being gaslit right
the argument two plus two equals five is
purely
gaslighting now i'm not saying that
everybody who's saying it knows that
but i am saying that its function is to
take all of the people
who feel like no wait a minute let me
explain to you why two plus two does not
equal five
and get them explaining it because
they're busy over here not paying
attention
right we are not paying attention to the
real thing which is
holy [ __ ] i think we just crossed that
threshold
that takes a functional entity and turns
it into madness
[Music]
you